this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app you
already know the cash up is the number
one finance app on the app store
what you might not know is that you can
also put cash up in your wallet with the
cash card
it's got boosts it's got great safety
features no credit check needed to get
one so that's good we'll talk about this
more later on in later on in the show
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market now I
thought we would start off the new
congratulations episode since last
episode was we got the new we got the
new sharp Shannon Sharpe has new words
not new but it's it's a the other meme
that I was alerted it to the whoa meme
where he's just going I mean he is a
cartoon dude that guy's awesome I know I
talked about it last time but when he
goes whoa whoa whoa unbelievable
let's let's here we go here we go here
at this like what is he doing dude I
love Shannon shop I want to be [ __ ]
friends with that guy dude he would not
like me you know he'd be like wow you'd
be really annoying you know he'd be like
wow man you're being mad annoying and
I'd be like a little problem and he'd be
like no no whoa whoa whoa don't do that
um so yeah dude we're here man I was in
a [ __ ] other country I was in another
country dude since I seen you last I've
been in another country
that's how [ __ ] disrespectful I'm
travelling all on your ass like I'm
[ __ ] Carmen Sandiego dude like I'm
[ __ ] carmine San Diego
every time I've I when I posted the meme
of how Melania Trump looked like a spy
versus spy everybody goes like this nah
she's Carmen Sandiego and I just go nope
she's what I said I don't like when I
tweet something and then somebody else
tries to be funny and back to it and and
like I don't know them and they're just
like yeah but also what about this you
should have said this and I just go like
this no what I said I just go you know
he's like 48 and he does that that's
amazing dude I can't wait to get older
and older and just [ __ ] be I think I
feel like the older you get the funnier
it is the more you do dumb [ __ ] you know
like if you're 20 and you do dumb [ __ ]
it's funny but if you're 20 if you're 45
and doing that same [ __ ] I mean that's
hilarious dude to be like dancing in a
supermarket and when you're 20 could be
funny but if you're 45 forget it that
third woe is the best or the fourth one
whatever it is you know which one I'm
talking about anyway I was in another
[ __ ] country dude that's her
disrespect he daddy gets man yeah I'll
do a podcast go to another country extra
paper scoop that up and then just
[ __ ] come back hello Cool J song dude
fresh out the private jet to Europe
extra paper
scoop that up dude yeah I'll go to
[ __ ] another country extra paper
scoop that up and then I'll [ __ ] come
back to LA dude like it didn't happen
I'll do that I'll go to another country
like it didn't happen anyway um so I'm
[ __ ] chilling I went to Vancouver or
as I like to call it cuvee you know I
mean just because I'm [ __ ] real
specific I make my agent say cuvee if
there you get me get gigs in Vancouver I
say where and it's
Vancouver and I say I don't know I'm
sorry I don't know what you're talking
about and I wait until they say oh sorry
cuvee and then I say sign it I'll do it
but I will not go to Vancouver I'm gonna
go to cuvee I only go to cuvee baby so I
went there and I did it I did a show in
Portland which by the way more
upside-down heads than I've ever seen in
my life so [ __ ] many long beards with
short hair
Portland figured out dude when you lay
an important thing you're like oh I
could only be in Portland
they got [ __ ] those those circular
glasses flannels like reddish beards
they're like not quite Canadian you know
what I'm talking about they're up north
but they're not quite big they're more
like the they're like the [ __ ] the
runt the runts of the [ __ ] Canadian
families moved down to Portland is what
it looks like and they just get wired
rim glasses and then have to like study
because they can't chop wood and it's
raining all the time so they [ __ ]
there they stay indoors and just like
[ __ ] do like smart stuff you know cuz
they can't be outside anyway um so
Portland was great I did two shows there
can't remember the [ __ ] theater at
all cuz every day is the same day and
everything [ __ ] blurs together it's
cool probably gonna get dementia when I
get older I do however remember the show
in Seattle and I will say it was in
Seattle even though it was in Snoqualmie
which is 40 minutes outside of Seattle
but whenever I [ __ ] say online yeah
thanks Seattle they say no you were in
snow Kwami and I say done Matt because I
[ __ ] you know what I mean people be
like yeah but come to Seattle no I
traveled [ __ ] 1,000 miles to get
there
you travel 30 if you want to comment if
not fine it's okay cuz it's gonna be
sold out anyway yeah man but the show
and Snoqualmie was okay the crowd the
the rooms are the room was all curtain'd
like every wall had a curtain on it and
then they were like curtains behind me
and like a curtain in the back it was
just like the laughter dissipates when
there's curtains if there's if there's
hard walls like we got here at the
congratulations log cabin those [ __ ]
things bounce off and the laughter sent
it's great but anyway but it was a good
it was a fine show and extra paper scoop
that up and then I went to [ __ ] in
Vancouver I'm sorry cuvee and I did two
shows there at the Molson Canadian
Theatre which was which were great I
love Canada man I I [ __ ] love Ken
every time I go to Canada I'm like how
much I do I love Canada so I did two
shows there extra paper scoop dad up I
did two shows there and that's two and
and that's it and now now here is the
best part about the whole weekend for me
okay first of all if you want to get
tickets I'm coming to Miami oh come on a
Fresno I'm coming to [ __ ]
Jacksonville I'm coming all sorts of
places
go get him Chris D'Elia calm here's the
best part about the weekend okay so I
wake up Portland I wake up in LA and I
text to my opener and my tour guy
passports because we're going to
Portland first and I figure I don't have
to but I would I want to remind these
fuck-ups that you got to bring your
passport because we're gonna end up
going to Vancouver right so we got to
get in there because guess what daddy's
gonna have his passport and if you don't
have your passport daddy's leaving you
behind and daddy's gonna go to cuvee
baby and extra paper scoop that up
all right now now we get to now I know I
text them that now the car picks us up
at my house so they come to my house
first even though they try to finagle it
every time they're like well could you
come pick me up no cause I'm the
headliner you come to me and then we
leave from here why the [ __ ] would I
want to make an extra stop even though
I'm [ __ ] you know what I mean extra
sticker extra stop no scoop that up
right no don't scoop up the extra stop
at all so I text them passports there
did my due diligence did my did my [ __ ]
didn't have to okay now
let me sign out of this app here so now
i I'm doing that I go to the I get I get
they show up they work out the merch it
they do that we put the merch in the car
were in the car and I say as we're
leaving for the airport from my house I
say you guys got your passports right
and my opener Mike goes like this yeah
well well you know on the way here I
realize I forgot it but I always keep my
my passport card in my wallet and that's
good for North America so it's all good
and I was like I told you to bring your
[ __ ] passport and he was like yeah
but it's alright it's why I have this in
case I forget my passport I always have
this which is so first of all so dumb to
get to have a fail-safe in case you
forget your passport just don't ever
forget your passport you [ __ ] [ __ ]
if you're going to another country okay
so now I'm pissed okay
doesn't take much to get pissed
especially when I'm on the road I don't
want to I want to be stress-free I got
to worry about performing now mister my
opener it's been 40 seconds I'm pissed
at my opener okay so Zach danke vo my
tour guys just going like this
idiot they forget to spay us what yeah
well why didn't you as my tour guy try
to [ __ ] make sure that he had his pad
for so far they're both failing okay so
I say all right man
guess what's happening if I get in and
you don't leave and yeah to go scoop up
my paper alright so now we do Portland
and the whole the whole time there's
this underlying stress was I don't know
if I'm gonna have to have [ __ ] hire a
new opener if I can go when I get there
- Cooper cause he's not gonna do it so I
get to we get to the we're driving to
Vancouver we're going from Seattle to
Vancouver Snoqualmie whatever the [ __ ]
and we drive in the driver gets it and
we get there I've never driven over any
borders ever in my life okay so we drive
over the border we park kind of we stop
and rather the drivers like you guys
have to stay in here I got to go in and
give them my paperwork first then you
can come out then when I come out then
you guys go back in so he comes out and
he's like go ahead and give it
there should we go there my openers a
little bit nervous you know he is cuz
you know that he forgot his passport you
know he wishes he has about it where he
has a passport card he says it's good
from a North America so okay I'm gonna
leave it on him
so I go we get the rudest [ __ ] guy
ever there and I don't understand when
people are [ __ ] rude about the border
[ __ ] it's like dude first of all take it
easy okay yeah you're standing up a
little bit higher why are they always a
little bit higher - it's so annoying
I'll let me get up on this [ __ ] step
podium why who gives a [ __ ] be my level
hey guess what you probably shorter than
me anyway okay who cares you still have
the control step up a step higher dude
it's like that a bit
Seinfeld hat about the pharmacy like why
they [ __ ] higher than you anyway so I
do the we go the guys never cracks a
smile nothing we do it all works out and
that and and Mike's I told you bro so
good for North America and Zach's like
he was right so we get over and like our
good man good well trust me I'm happy
I'm happy we got over alright so we do
this show we do two shows and then we
come back the next day we go but we're
flying back to LA all right so we get to
the airport and we are loading up the
bags and all the [ __ ] we check in and
the lady says passports and I give her
my passport and Zach gives her his
passport
and then Mike gives her a passport card
and she says where's your passport and
he says well that's my passport card and
she says oh this is good for land and
see it says it right on the card it says
on the card good for land and sea now
let me tell you what that means in case
you're listening and you're as [ __ ]
stupid as my opener that means you can
either use the passport card to drive
over the border or swim over the border
or be on a boat okay so he says oh it's
good for North America and she says no
it's just for land and sea and he says
oh and she says well look I'm gonna let
it go this time but you might actually
have a problem at customs when you get
there and I'm [ __ ] smile and I can't
wait to be on the other end of the
[ __ ] customs and be looking at my
shitty no shouldered opener and going
like this can't wait can't wait because
it's gonna be a major told you so
okay cannot [ __ ] wait and Zack the
whole times like hey okay so now we get
to that [ __ ] like electronic kiosk
where you put your passport in you know
and he go he looks at me and he says
where do I put this and I said hey man
I don't know because we're not traveling
Leo and he actually said Linden see what
the [ __ ] he actually said what the [ __ ]
I thought you know we're flying over the
land idiot err you [ __ ] up so now he
gets it he's like we're gonna put the
card knows like you can't put the card
anywhere man you need to put the
passport somewhere exactly and so we're
going over the [ __ ] thing and they
say well you go first and they point
over to the guy and he's like I hope I
get a good guy and Mike goes over there
and I see his [ __ ] ass face like just
like like agreeing and being a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know just agreeing so hard and
saying stuff like you know he's calling
you know he's calling America his home
do you know what I mean just trying to
go back home like that's what he was
doing like it was some [ __ ] movie in
1940 where he's like oh I'm just trying
to go back home you know and so I got
there I got and we see him go through
customs and I was like it looks like he
made it you know and then Zacks like oh
looks like you wouldn't did making him
go to the other room he did detain in
them and I was like no Zack it says to
the gates he's like no they're detained
in them so now I'm extra mad at Zack
because he's not getting what's going on
and also I'm secretly hoping Zack
right because I want them to detain him
and I get through and my it Mike's
waiting there I was like you lucky
[ __ ] and Zach and Zach's like oh
I got through all and I was like I knew
we got through man why are you Jack now
act like he was detaining him anyway he
got through but I was like dude I wish
you learned a lesson and he's like I did
dude because emotionally and [ __ ]
mentally he went through it but dude
when that [ __ ] girl said this says
land and sea oh dude I wanted to piss
myself
I wanted to piss in the shape of
Australia on my jeans yeah dude
and the guy was like you need the
passport book for air for the airport
always and he's like okay sir he was
trying he was being so respectful see
that's the thing I don't like when
people are respectful look it says right
here the passport card cannot be used
for international air travel I'm gonna
take care I'm gonna take a picture of
that right there and send it to my
[ __ ] bitch-ass opener but that's the
thing dude when people are respectful
only when they need to be respectful
that's not cool dude that's not cool
that's why I like Bobby Lee dude he's
the same way he is for everybody if you
met Obama he would be like what's up
Obama I mean come here feel my balls or
whatever the far you know but yeah
people you got it you gotta love people
who are the same with everybody and my
opener is not he's respectful to people
who are who we need something to and
he's not [ __ ] respectful once he gets
to know you and that's [ __ ] up anyway
Landon see Riddick you louts so now we
got like an hour and a half and I see of
course Alonzo Bodden in the airport
because I always see Alonzo Bodden in
the airport and I say see in LA
comedians see each other at the airport
so much that even when you you don't
even stop to talk you could be like
friends with him like Alonzo Bodden is
my friend he was on the phone and I just
literally went April what's up and we
slap hands I said and I kept walking
imagine see someone you know there but
you stop you talk to him you know but I
knew I was gonna see him [ __ ] Tuesday
at the improv probably anyway you know
that guy is a [ __ ] killer comic by
the way Alonzo Bodden I love I love
Alonzo Bodden if you have a chance go
see Alonzo Bodden if he's in your ticket
if your inner city get tickets look them
up so
he's also the biggest man I've ever seen
in my entire life the guy is [ __ ]
he's like the Fantastic Four
what's the The Rock guy what's his name
the thing dude Alonzo Bodden is if
everyone in the world fought to the
death Alonzo Bodden would come in 17th
that's how [ __ ] Big E is and strong
so anyway so anyway now we're sitting
and we have like an hour and a half
waiting for that and waiting for the
food and they're waiting for the plane
and then we sit down we order food and
this is something this is something that
guys do that girls don't do and this was
the [ __ ] dude I love doing [ __ ] like
this I don't like pranks
I don't like pranks you know I've
pranked my opener I wore the same [ __ ]
as he did on stage and made him look
like a [ __ ] beta but I don't
like pranks and I don't like when like
my buddy was like all you got a prank
this guy do that my buddy loves pranks
but always always get me to do pranks
too my opener I don't want to do pranks
I don't like that [ __ ] okay
so one time no not once I've got it I
got it myself so now we're sitting we
order food and we order these [ __ ]
chicken tusks and sandwiches by the way
if you're gonna order something and the
word if you're ever wondering what to
order at a restaurant and the [ __ ] says
Tuscan in it go ahead and [ __ ] order
it cuz I don't know what flavor that is
but Tuscan tastes [ __ ] good I swear
to God if something says Tuscan gimme
two so if it's a chicken Tuscan chicken
sandwich dude go [ __ ] get out of here
get out of here I think you ever you
ever go down on a check and it tastes
good and you just look up and you just
say now that's some Tuscan [ __ ] my
[ __ ] dad listens to this podcast you
know so under the Tuscan under the
Tuscan dude have you ever been under the
Tuscan Sun well bro that's when you get
the illest an of all time how dope is
Tuscany is that what it is Tuscany in
Italy is that what they mean is Italian
Tuscan under the Tuscan Sun dude have
you ever seen under the Tuscan Sun
imagine watching under the Tuscan
with [ __ ] what's-her-name Diane Lane
this oh of course
on the okay let me tell you something if
you thought of the movie the under the
Tuscan Sun movie poster you if you don't
know what it is
imagine what under the Tuscan Sun the
movie poster is you there that's what it
is that's what it is she's in front of a
brown wall with a picture of outside on
it and there's a guy off screen handing
her flowers chick see that and just go
let's go
chicks see that poster and say is it on
Netflix or Hulu chicks look at that and
say I'll get Amazon Prime for that all
you need if you want to get the chicks
[ __ ] involved with your streaming
service
get under the tuscan sun done fifty
percent already fifty percent of your
revenue is from chicks get that and the
[ __ ] anything with Sandra Bullock
even the [ __ ] movies where she play
it with like the net so wow what the
[ __ ] was I talking about
no clue what was I talk oh yeah okay so
I got the Tuscan chicken sandwiches and
I say yeah let me get a Tuscan chicken
sandwich and then my opener says yeah
I'll do that too and then Zack goes like
this
yeah three so we wait twenty minutes
takes way too long to get the Tuscan
chicken sandwiches maybe they needed to
[ __ ] go get them from Tuscany right
that's the stupid joke that everyone
always does hey ordered a burger what
they have to [ __ ] kill the cow yeah
okay so anyway I get we get the
sandwiches
they're so good but guess what they're
small and there's not enough chicken in
him alright so I say man my opener
always says Mike's always says I could
get I could get more I hear another one
and I say yeah let's get another one
we'll get another round a Tuscan chicken
sandwiches all right so we do that and
then Zach who's [ __ ] puffin on his
jewel which is annoying his [ __ ]
anywhere shorts dude he where she's the
guy who kind of guy wears shorts and a
long sleeve sweater the [ __ ] are you in
nwa so
so now we were waiting for the
sandwiches and Zach goes like this
I want to Starbucks and we're like well
let's just wait for the sandwiches she
says now I'm gonna get a Starbucks you
want something I say no and he says okay
I'll be back so as he leaves we get two
sandwiches the three sandwiches okay now
I eat my sandwich all right and Mike eat
his sandwich and Mike says hey man you
you think zach can [ __ ] he's gonna
come back before we finish these and I
said bro I already am ahead yeah I'm
eating half a Zach sandwich if you eat
the other half [ __ ] it he says okay he
says let's just tell him we cancel the
order okay and you go yeah we'll do that
so we tell him week so we eat the
[ __ ] they're done take the P takes
the plates away then Zach comes back
with [ __ ] three Starbucks's he was
like yeah I get you guys Starbucks this
oh the food doesn't come yet and we go
now we cancelled it and the mic is so
bad at this year Mike's like we
cancelled it and I'm like yeah now we
can't so that we thought we don't need
another [ __ ] thing is like and Zach
says yeah that's true I don't need to
either another sandwich and then so we
get to so we eat so we finish it we pay
the check we leave and then on the plane
we're not sitting with each other so I
text on the chain hey Zach and he says I
say I need to tell you something and he
says yeah I says remember how we set we
ordered we went to order the second
sandwiches this is before we take off
and they say we need to get the ordered
the sandwiches that we ordered
sandwiches we cancelled it he says yeah
and I said well guess what we didn't
cancel them we we they got here when
you're at Starbucks and we [ __ ] it and
before I wrote we ate them Mike chimed
in and wrote this kind of [ __ ] ruins my
day we are them he didn't check his
[ __ ] goddamn it he didn't check his
[ __ ] spellcheck we are them so he's
what we and I wrote no we ate them oh
wow Mike [ __ ] and I wrote Oh Mike
[ __ ] ruin the day
he ruined the [ __ ] prank and Zacks
sitting there hungry on the plane after
he ate a [ __ ] dude and we were
laughing we were laughing now that's
something chicks would never do and
that's why I like being a guy because
you could [ __ ] [ __ ] that dude I ate
your sandwich [ __ ] you went to
Starbucks dude don't sleep you know what
I'm getting ready to play you went to
Starbucks [ __ ] I ate your
sandwich you'll Beach that's why each
will fit that's why I just seeing what
you fat [ __ ] [ __ ] you beat
weightless try to do it that's how it
should be he says fat [ __ ]
first off eight just a G Tuscan chicken
first off ancient Tuscan chicken and
your popcorn dude he got pie this is
Zach dude he got [ __ ] popcorn she was
like you got fries and she was like we
don't have fries we have truffle popcorn
no and he says oh yeah I get that the
[ __ ] gets truffled popcorn as a
substitute for you should be [ __ ]
shamed for even trying to substitute it
and he was like y'all get that and then
she brought the thing without the
popcorn he says oh where the fries and
she said well you mean the popcorn he's
at oh yeah and then she left and he said
what Anderson you got [ __ ] truffle
popcorn man anyway we love pranking
babies
we love pranking babies that's what we
do all right I'm gonna do it mid roll
here would you only got one right here
right just the three of them okay uh
Robin Hood Robin Hood is is an investing
app that lets you buy and sell stocks
ETFs options and cryptos check this out
all commission-free
you probably like yeah but if I cross
thousand dollars not as Commission free
they strive to make Financial Services
work for everyone
not just the wealthy non-intimidating
way for stock market newcomers to invest
for the first time with true confidence
other brokerages charged charge up to
ten dollars for every trade but Robin
Hood doesn't charge Commission fees
trade stocks and keep all of your
profits easy to understand charts and
market data place a trade in just four
taps on your smartphone I never knew how
to do this stuff because it seemed like
it was too hard but they make it very
easy it's you tap it on your phone you
go pack a pack and all of a sudden
you're you're in the game Robin Hood web
platform also lets you view stock
collections 100 most popular sectors
like entertainment and social media and
curated categories like female CEOs and
analysts ratings of buy hold sell for
every top every stock yeah I don't know
it's kind of cool you go get in there I
had fun going in there poking all around
and and figuring out what to do and try
and making some money my babies Robin
Hood is giving listeners a free stock
like Apple Ford you understand try it
and you get if you're listener here you
get free stock like Apple Ford or Sprint
uh you ever heard of them to help build
your portfolio sign up at congrats dot
Robin Hood dot-com that's Congrats dot
Robin Hood com SeatGeek
getting tickets online could be far too
complicated it's annoying I know it
trust me I'm in the biz with hundreds of
sites and varying levels of reliability
it's hard to know who to trust
that's why SeatGeek is the way to go
seat geek pulls millions of tickets into
one place so you can easily find the
seats you want for a price you're
willing to pay that's important there's
nothing quite like being there in person
and seat geek will let you get closer to
the action for great for a great value
it's design C geek is designed to make
your ticket buying experience easier
than ever and it is but searching it
searches multiple sick ticket sites and
grades
every ticket based on value SeatGeek
helps you immediately identify the best
seats that fit your budget I actually
had some friends that I wanted to come
to my own show and I already like used
the comps and I didn't want to mess with
it on the theater I didn't want to like
force him to do it and I don't want to I
didn't there weren't any seats that I
could get him so I went on SeatGeek
myself and I got tickets for my friends
that way it's it got him in easy it seat
geeks right best of all my listeners get
twenty to twenty dollars off their first
seat geek purchase just download the
seat geek app and enter promo code
congrats today
that's promo code congrats for twenty to
twenty dollars off your first seat geek
purchase seat geek life's an event we
have the tickets square cash you already
know the cash up is the number one
finance app in the App Store what you
might not know is that you can also put
cash app in your wallet with the cash
card it's the only depa debit card that
offers instant rewards and comes to
comes packed with premium features not
even a credit card can offer like boosts
save up to 10% instantly at Whole Foods
Wendy's or Chipotle and more of your
favorite spots or even $1 off coffee
every time you swipe your cash card at
coffee shops across the country you know
that's what I like cuz my baby I love
coffee the cash card puts you in control
of your money with an extra in-app
safety feature well they have a few
extra in-app safety features that let
you pause your card with a touch unlike
a credit card there are no fees ever
ever and a credit card check isn't
required to get one so download you the
cash app and get your cash card for free
visit the Apple Store or Google Play
market now and of course when you
download the cash app and enter the
referral code congrats do that for all
that and you'll receive $5 and the cash
app will send $5 to the times up Legal
Defense Fund it's a true win-win for
everybody so come on my babies
let's get it going cash FC geek and also
Robin Hood you guys you know you know
what I'm saying my babies whoops I
forgot to do something dude I'm sorry
guys you do it I promised you something
last episode and I forgot to do
something I do
three action anyway we're having a good
time here you know what I mean hearing
the congratulations so we ate Zacks
lunch and that's some that's some [ __ ]
that chicks would never do
imagine chicks or ring and then being
like let's get another round and then
the girl goes I'm gonna get a Starbucks
and then the girls just go like let's
eat her [ __ ] food and then imagine
that happening and then the girl coming
back and being like what the heck didn't
order we're like we cancelled it I'm the
girl would be like okay well that's kind
of weird but mmm okay I wasn't part of
that decision but okay should we can
consensus but um okay
and then imagine on the plane first of
all I'm not another plane they weren't
[ __ ] together would never happen
girls will be together no matter what
and then imagine them texting each other
and being like hey guess what guess what
Rebecca what someone I need to tell you
remember do you remember when we went
you went to Starbucks and we decided to
cancel we said we decided to cancel the
food yeah guess what we ate a [ __ ]
anyway let me get home let's watch under
the Tuscan Sun yeah do it but I've
always been [ __ ] gangster like that
eatin people's food you know I have
always been gangster like that dude
gimme yeah I'm talking about again cuz I
uh
yeah man one time dude and I think it
started when I was a kid cuz when I was
a kid we were at this we had this
Batmobile toy that was the [ __ ] it was
just a Batmobile
there's a [ __ ] Batmobile it was like
that big it was a big my brother and I
will play with it and we're always
fighting over it now I here's something
here my dad [ __ ] up my dad [ __ ] up
royally
here's how he [ __ ] up he goes like
this you know what so they don't fight
I'm gonna get them another Batmobile and
they can just play with the batmobile's
now you might not know where we [ __ ]
up already but I do I do
so he brought back the Batmobile and he
said that now nah he's got to
you never fight over them again and
guess what we fought over the new one
dude hey Dad you [ __ ] up if you're
gonna get one new Batmobile you get two
new Batmobiles and then you get rid of
the old one because now this is of
course some spoiled brat [ __ ] but let me
tell you something dude of course we're
gonna want the [ __ ] new one the other
one I had like a the the headlights came
up and only one King kind of came up and
the other one was kind of janky I told
him last night I was like hey you [ __ ]
that up huh and he was like what I was
trying to do a nice thing I like that so
you to try to do it like that I'll [ __ ]
it up
you know it's deeper and deeper issues
steeper and so yeah that was it but we
were prepared man my dad used to hang my
dad used to hold things out like my toys
out of the crib and I would be like just
out of reach and I'd be trying to get
him my mom be like what the [ __ ] are you
doing and he would be like I'm preparing
him for life he can't get everything he
wants literally so now the one time dude
I my brother was in his crib my dad says
he has a memory of this and he watched
it and I'll never forget it and my
brother was holding on to the crib just
like this like just holding on to the
crib just standing up like you know
baby's always look like they're busing
and not because they can't ever stand
still or whatever and they're just like
[ __ ] like this and so he was holding
on to the crib and my dad said I walked
by and just went boop boop and knocked
his hands over and they [ __ ] fell on
his ass that's what's up dude don't put
that [ __ ] right in my face I'll knock
you down dude yeah I know there is
nothing I used to like more when I was a
kid then [ __ ] making my brother fall
down
it was so dick dude I would knock my
brother down all the time if I you know
what I used to love doing I don't I
wonder if there's anybody out there that
you that love doing this [ __ ] I used to
love doing this I used to take the big
pill okay
I used to take first of all I used to
take the little pillows and I used to
rock it I'm at my brother's head when he
started walking and he would I would
love to try and get it just god I'm a
[ __ ] lunatic I would love to get it
to just like just the amount to where
I'd throw it not hard enough but not too
light that it would hit his head and
he would like Teeter for a little bit
and he's tried to catch his balance
until he fell down I used to get that
sweet spot till he we'd take like I
choose to see like how many steps he
would have to take before he fell down I
think I got to like seven once he was
just like no no and then gone right so
when he got bigger I used too much like
all these pillows they don't work
anymore [ __ ] that dude daddy got crafty
I took the [ __ ] pillows you used to
sit on I dude I wouldn't take those
[ __ ] ass throw pillows [ __ ] down my
brother thought he was gonna get too big
well I'm getting the pillows that we
[ __ ] sit on [ __ ] that's what we're
doing we're getting the pillows with the
zipper on it and we're gonna rock it
those cuz now I'm big I could carry
those to it and I would rock it those
big-ass pillows I'd make them take seven
or eight eight steps to sayonara still
dude that's it
oh you taking a [ __ ] are you going
are you going to [ __ ] a do it how
about this man Hale anoche hey how about
my or you might open her dude you better
get your passport card cuz you're
traveling over the border to [ __ ]
sayonara as ville that's what you're
doing dude that's what you're doing hey
take a trip hey get your passport card
here you go have a [ __ ] fun time
sayonara
dude I would [ __ ] he would take so
many [ __ ] steps over to sayonara Z oh
man and he loved it too he would laugh
so hard don't get me wrong man I didn't
make him cry one time I did is the
zipper hit his eye was [ __ ] awful
that's pretty much the last time I did
that my mom got real mad at me I was
like mine was a zipper
I just rock it the pillows to his head I
didn't know that zipper was gonna hit
his eye and she was like you can't rock
it pillows to your [ __ ]
three-year-old brother's head I was like
gonna stop again I'm so big I'm using
the [ __ ] bill parisa I'm gonna throw
rocks at this [ __ ] I'm gonna
take the whole bed frame and just push
it over on him I loved making my brother
fall down how cute was it having [ __ ]
brothers and dude how cure kids man
once we there's a video of us walking up
the driveway and I had a [ __ ] stick
and I was like I'm an old man and my dad
was like filming oh you're an old man
huh and then my brother's right behind
me and he doesn't have a stick but he
was just like I'm an old man too and I'm
like man you got to get the [ __ ]
stick [ __ ] like I still look at that
that tape and I'm like that's so shitty
that
just tried to copy my [ __ ] but didn't
even take the [ __ ] like didn't
actually get the stick come on dude I do
the work dude that's why I knocked you
out your ass over with the [ __ ]
pillows bro you deserved it you know you
didn't deserve a pillow in your eye but
I mean a [ __ ] zipper in your eye but
don't don't use this use a stick
otherwise you're gonna go to [ __ ] you
got a a one-way ticket to sayonara
Saville dude I loved my brother I got I
love my brother I got him ready for real
life dude you know if you're gonna come
see me go did Chris D'Elia calm and I
know that's it's disrespecting you for a
little bit you've got to keep you guys
on your toes I'm talking and all of a
sudden and you had to hear it and you
had to hear it and that's fine dude cuz
this is this is what life is you know
[ __ ] man I love my life you know it's so
cool that I get to do what I want to do
I put out a tweet the other day that I
get to do what I want to do for a living
dude I'm so fortunate and I'm so happy
and I'm so grateful thank you for all
everyone who ever has come to a show it
really makes me feel really good that I
get to do this and we're all in this
together you know we're trying to
[ __ ] build this log cabin and get
this cult going and I you know I got a
cult because honestly they pull up some
questions cuz honestly you know it gets
hard out there man
sometimes you you put out a tweet and
people [ __ ] come at you and say like
you suck you know but as long as I got
the [ __ ] cult going strong it's on
baby I tweeted some [ __ ] about that
Rockstar videogame thing that Red Dead
Redemption and everyone got so mad I
guess I missed worded it you know I was
trying to say that people don't really
care if they're tweeting and that's all
they're doing but I realized - after I
tweeted it that movements do exist I
guess I mean I I know that but I didn't
really think about it it is weird how
you can
I mean outrage culture is [ __ ] crazy
and it's definitely gone too far but you
can really start a movement just
by tweeting it's [ __ ] weird huh you
never used to be able to do that that's
why everyone would get away with [ __ ]
you know so yeah I mean people are upset
with everything like I was making fun of
[ __ ] Takashi on on seven and I
started cause I I said like that she's
so [ __ ] sexy there's something so
sexy about her you know and I started
calling her Jumanji part two and people
are like hey somebody was like it's not
bad to be a woman you shouldn't make fun
of it it's like yeah dude okay I'm also
making fun of his name like I'm just
being silly you know it's like you
should literally just look at those
tweets and just be like just look at
those tweets read every one of my tweets
and remember I love the guy in the
background - huh
he has no idea once it's so funny when
you realize a guy in the back real Lonzo
so you know it's so funny - because he's
actually you can tell in his huh do you
hear that you hear that huh I know that
what that huh is that ha is a wait is
this that guy's B it's a racist huh he
he thinks I was just like some black guy
thing is he saying
and then he probably realized that he's
saying that ain't no problem but he was
like oh it's just a new black thing I
don't know about that's what he's doing
he's like oh this black guy is doing the
black thing that's so racist dude huh
I can tell bro I'm good man guys racist
just based off uh-huh
yeah let's start some questions my
babies sometimes we get going with the
questions is that it was that who he was
talking to skip bayless I've ever seen
skip bayless is Instagram
first of all skip bayless
what are you up did somebody draw you
are you a [ __ ] superhero are you an
alter healed look at skip bayless dude
skip bayless will be like he thought he
does that thing Mark Wahlberg does
waking up and getting at him and it's
like 3:00 10:00 in the morning dude how
hard to skip bayless have an orgasm by
the way Skip Bayless has an orgasm so
hard that he blacks out afterwards for
[ __ ] 12 seconds and then he wakes up
and he's just like holy [ __ ] and he's
like turn on the Dolphins game dude skip
bayless wakes up so [ __ ] I bet he
wakes up look at skip bayless dude the
way we got a google this guy when he
wait this is how he wakes up he wakes up
when he goes I guess he goes like like
he's excited for another day guys like
that are crazy anyway let's start some
questions huh skip and Shannon just goes
ah that's so funny
skip bayless I woke up three Austin
Lopez at Austin Lopez what topics do you
get on your pizza bro you can get a
bunch of topics but we don't get his
[ __ ] any fruit there [ __ ] this
pineapple [ __ ] you get pepperoni I
get that and then I also like to get a
veggie [ __ ] I'd like to get the veggie
and then I like what also why are you
[ __ ] asking me this who cares you
really give a [ __ ] what I put on my
pizza pepto-bismol you really give a
[ __ ] what am i what are you a [ __ ]
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle you give a
[ __ ] about pizza this much why is it a
discussion what top is you get on your
pizza [ __ ] you know what I get car
parts how about that alright what else
people are you're not like how about
when
people called dog Warner's lipstick well
it Trevor mess 23 well it looks like
that you know it looks like that every
time I twist my dog's dick the lipstick
comes out like an ellipse - I can do
that I do have to manually do it I go to
my dog and I go and I open and I twist
his penis and it comes out anyway I'll
never be running for [ __ ] mayor um oh
I mean come on bro look at this guy
trying to be [ __ ] cute with his
thoughts on people who take a [ __ ] in a
urinal bro what where are you glad Amala
what are you talking about
I'm had you walked into a [ __ ] like a
Diamondbacks game game bathroom like
with him playing the Diamondbacks and
you're just like em I gotta take a pic
oh my god and he's sitting there taking
a [ __ ] rump in a in a urinal just like
and I he would be doing that and I would
be the [ __ ] skip bayless Oh one time
I went to go take a piss and I was
peeing next to the guy by the way let me
tell you something girls you probably
don't know this and guys don't talk
about this a lot they don't talk about
this a lot but you urinals suck they
suck do you know how much how much piss
is on my jeans and shoes because it
always [ __ ] bounces back it splashes
back hey girls
just so you know guys have piss all over
their jeans and shoes always always dude
if you see any urinal everywhere across
the nation probably cross the globe
except for in Asia because they [ __ ] in
a hole
there's piss lakes under them you have
to literally stand far back so you don't
stand in piss while you're pissing and
that is a problem that is a problem that
is a problem so yeah so it always
splashes back so I always opt to
for the [ __ ] stall you know but then
sometimes I stand far back and what and
I stood far back at one time I did it
and the guy goes like this hey man I was
like a kid though and he was like hey
man you want to get a little closer or
what like he was all mad I said what are
you talking about he thought I was
trying to look at his dick you know hey
guy that guy you have another question
or is that it those are some [ __ ]
bunk ask questions while I was not doing
his job what are your thoughts on the
Harlem Globetrotters dude have you ever
seen their this [ __ ] jerk almost patola
Italian the Harlem Globetrotters of the
ship
they do all sorts of tricks and [ __ ]
what is it during the all-star game or
something I don't know man who are they
what did they do what was what that you
know what the Harlem Globetrotters are
such an 80s thing like it they probably
still around today because they have
like you know Harlem Globetrotter
purists but like they had the bat the
ball that was rainbow and the the things
and they used to do like trick stuff and
play trick players I remember as a kid
thinking why don't they play in the real
league there's so much better than
regular basketball players because they
could do all the tricks as a kid I
didn't understand I was like well
[ __ ] Michael Jordan can't do those
bouncing off the ball things they can't
twist around and do a [ __ ] thing
don't even train trampoline for the [ __ ]
look at these guys names Curley Johnson
is there a [ __ ] 80s name more than
Curley Johnson unbelievable they used to
[ __ ] him for the Holy Grail Charles and
they would flip didn't they have like a
team that would play against them always
Washington Generals and they would
always be like the the [ __ ] they'd
let them play against them and the
Washington Generals would be the [ __ ]
and hond [ __ ] were just [ __ ]
welcome Hubert Osby I mean these names
Paul Gaffney Paul Showtime Gaffney they
all had names with them you know
Hubert geese Osby that's a bad one geese
you know Showtime
boo
was one of his name's curly boo rah I
mean so cool for kids though man
kids loved the Harlem Globetrotters I
love the armboard I didn't even like
basketball like the Harlem Globetrotters
as a kid I wanted to be a Harlem
Globetrotter look at the acting that
they do it's like WWF but anyway I think
they're cool man I like guys like that
that guys that have fun you know that's
what sports should be [ __ ] all this
competition you know
did you see the Rondo and Chris Paul
thick dude how sneaky was Rondo when he
did that [ __ ] I thought it was Chris
Paul's fault and then he saw the
slowdown [ __ ] that the Rockets sent in
to the officials bro Rondo [ __ ] spit
on Chris Paul oh man what is this far
and away that movie I think Tom Cruise
did that once in that movie but Rondo
[ __ ] spit in Chris Paul and then
Chris Paul put his finger in his face by
the way Chris Paul don't do that
punch bro he was so mad he'd know what
to do he was like I shouldn't I
shouldn't punch but I'll push my finger
in his face bro you should have punched
him as hard as you possibly could have
he spit in his face
cuz it would still been his fault man
that's crazy dude Rondo is a sneak [ __ ]
you know for doing that and yet is the
best part was to when he spit he had his
hands on his hips like he was like what
I'm not doing that not a problem
and then Chris Baldwin huh and most his
finger to say was that okay Evan
Crowther act Crowther underscore Evan
how about frenemies hmm yeah I go on my
podcast sometimes cuz yeah I'm [ __ ]
disrespectful to you but um and that's
being respectful you know that being
disrespectful is being respectful
because me being true self how about you
frenemies that that saying is so dumb
what does it mean you're enemies okay is
that what you mean the guy said like
aegis enemies right yeah I guess or is
it like a friendly like ribbing thing or
is like you hate somebody but you got to
keep him close what even is a frenemy
that's a stupid thing I don't like when
people book cute words together just
because they
rhyme or whatever you know like what's
another one like that
oh you know what's like that [ __ ] when
girls named Ashley think it's cute to
call themselves smashley how your
uh-uh-uh smashley you know how many dude
if your name is Matt yeah Ashley and you
and your friends call you smashley get
new friends and if it was your choice
and your life um yeah dude smashley so
not cute and original also how long you
had to do that for to the whole
perspective on your [ __ ] I'm
not gonna not enough oxygen that's for
sure
I just added a show in San Antonio
tickets on crystallis Chris D'Elia calm
I got a second show in a San Antonio
backing up that [ __ ] Brinks truck
dude oh [ __ ] where's the dumb bar
where's the dumb bark truck las got some
Las Vegas San Ynez got some coming up
Windsor Ontario San Antonio farting on
your mother [ __ ] you understand me
straight up [ __ ] and farting on your
mother [ __ ] that's it that's the only
questions we got well we may end early
man you guys are [ __ ] a good group of
babies but I'll tell you what though you
know what it is man it's like every
episode sometimes gonna be longer than
our sometimes not gonna be longer now or
sometime gonna be shortened ours that's
gonna be an hour you know what I mean
but I love it dude I love you guys
yeah I told some stories of wanna kick
it
I guess we'll finish up do it it's been
two [ __ ] over 50 minutes you know
some use episodes I'm gonna be shorter
doing whatever the [ __ ] you want darlin
how about a guy that calls a girl darlin
or sweetheart
it's a sexist all right I'm gonna head
on out of here
download the cash app free on the App
Store or Google Play market and two
rewards code congrats get $5 and give $5
- times up
follow-the-leader buy tickets on
crystally accom new dates for 2019
announcing soon we've got some merch
this has been flying off the shelves so
go get some merch and represent the cult
here and subscribe rate and review the
show it really helps also download my
app you can go on the App Store and just
download Christmas typing Chris D'Elia
and you get the app you get to see the
podcast before anybody else so thanks
guys videos go up every Tuesdays
Wednesdays and that's what's up thanks a
lot you guys are great and remember
[Music]